[Musique]
faut que nos témoignages concordent
qu'il telle personne sera ce qu'on a
fait
[Musique]
je m'appelle holder jus de la police du
comté toile inc ouais c'est moi qui
n'aime les élèves ont découvert ça ce
matin il était en sortie
votre fille est elle déjà fugué madame
marcelle rousies non j'en ai fait
quelque chose c'est pas fille vous ne
devriez pas être ici monsieur verser
[Musique]
cette affaire sur laquelle tu avais
travaillé il ya quelques années
le gamin qui se prenait pour picasso
mère prostituée retrouvée la tête
presque tanger un cadavre ce matin tu
veux trouver liens y en aura aucun parce
qu'on a eu huit tueurs ya trois ans la
nuit à lambres fin de l'histoire c'est
quoi cet endroit d'une bonne baston
armes s'il te plaît à faire je te ferai
pékin
tout peut arriver sur ses terres
lieutenant voyez un mec peut-être un mec
qui devait rester anonyme
tu crois qu'on pourchasse le mauvais
gars vous est peut-être prison course
une centaine de fois on n'arrivera
jamais à l'attraper
ces enfants sont tellement souffrance
c'est moi que vous essayez de sauver ou
si vous même
oh
[Musique]
mais foi
[Rires]
non
il
ah ah
bah on a
ouais
[Musique]
sevré de ballons
83 hommes
tous morts en moins de cinq minutes
[Musique]
c'est une chose effrayante dnse que la
mort peut atteindre les hommes y sont
morts
la mine les a pris pour les hommes
comment cette charmante ville de la
belle s'en est sorti dans un amour
disant faut bien quelqu'un fasse tourner
la ville est une ville où il n'y a que
les femmes
[Musique]
frimeur pour les bandits griffin est à
la recherche de run good
il tuera tous ceux pour qui rend et
goodman liste
ces braves gens de crime dans les ce et
reporter leurs oeufs aujourd'hui n'ont
plus d'ordre plus personnel
et quand ils découvrir à quel genre
d'habitants vit annabelle que dieu vous
vient d'en être
monsieur on est beaucoup plus forte que
vous le pensez faire quelque chose à
faire
[Musique]
j'attire le malheur ça ne fait au moins
un point commun c'est la terre du
poignard et du fusil
c'est la terre
c'est changer
restons tous calme et discutons comme
des personnes civilisées un prix entre
et il suggère que d'abord nous baissions
noaa
sur le dow fille
qui sont ces gens elle ne nous avait
jamais eu il ya sept ans quand elle
était portée disparue elle était aveugle
vous vous souvenez du déroulé des
événements qui ont mené à votre
disparition
[Musique]
je veux que vous fermez les yeux
je veux que vous imaginiez tout ce que
je vais vous raconter comme si vous
l'aviez nec
comme si vous étiez avec moi comme si
vous étiez mois
[Musique]
je n'aime pas disparu
je suis restée présente tout du mans
[Musique]
mais la plus grosse erreur que j'ai
faite a été de croire que si je tendais
un beau filet jeunes être après que de
belles choses
[Musique]
je me souviens de tout
au hockey
ce qu'ils sont
peut-être est-ce qu'ils demandent
beijing news
de tels scores ronnie se pose plus
québec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je note qu'on observe le manga
l'injustice l'intolérance et les défis
environnementaux gigantesque il est
difficile d'imaginer un avenir radieux
mais c'est possible et on doit y
parvenir moment elle se met à l'eau
ça devait être galère avant que le
système existe il ne va rien t'arriver
ça va bien se passer je suis suis oula
devenir insouciant comme en fait état
mais combien de temps le bonheur dure
réellement dans la vraie vie
[Musique]
cette conscience système parce que ça
marche vraiment qui est privé doit
rester privé je me demande seulement si
on doit le faire directement
qu'entendez vous par le faire
directement [ __ ] qu'est ce qu'on peut
y faire
rien n'arrive par hasard
[Musique]
c'est un cauchemar horrible et sans fin
regardez
après tout va seul
[Musique]
voilà un
à voir
oh
[Musique]
rien n'arrive par hasard
portas
[Musique]
je m'appelle built and chez voici mon
collègue golden ford on travaille pour
l'unité des sciences comportementales du
hebei et dans ce cadre on interroge des
gars comme toi mais si vous allez à 20k
ville il faut vous parlez avec kemper
surnommé le tueur d'étudiantes vous
croyez que kemper se confiera nous il ne
s'arrêtera paix et si shepard découvre
tu va interroger un tueur il va piquer
une crise il est plus facile de demander
le pardon que la permission ou comptait
dire et faire tout ce qui vous chante
on avait décidé que personne ne méritait
notre mépris est pourri que pas fait
changer d'avis ceux qui arrivent à ces
hommes est normal mais leur façon de
gérer ne l'est pas j'ai décidé de les
tuer voilà tout notre boulot c'est pas
de sympathiser avec l'équipe
salut les filles entre blues vient
d'électrocuter piquant salue le chaman
est juste quand on était à sacramento
si ça ne te convient pas rempile avec
les universitaires qui puisse encore au
lit où on oublie la jane je crois que
notre rôle est aussi préventif on est le
fbi holden c'est pas ça notre rôle pour
l'instant
[Applaudissements]
sans s'engueuler
la corde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
winning the one that i mean girls night
in a country manager donner accès
[Musique]
dont lyon à pipo that has riches
mais ici dans ce monde il y a de bonnes
personnes et de mauvaises personnes je
ne me laisserai pas contraindre à la
soumission
vous avez lu la réplique masculine est
ce que vous voulez reprendre mais
puisque je ne me laisserai pas
contraindre la soumission
pardon monsieur votre femme est sur la
ligne 2 ce qui m'intéresse vraiment ce
sont les vrais rôles je sais pas si je
pourrai payer l'essence jusque là j'ai
que 83 dollars sur mon compte en banque
une audition une recherche des femmes à
conventionnels parce que ça veut dire
bonjour mesdames je suis sam sylvia
s'est clos excusez moi c'est quoi glow
gorgeous ladies of running
est-ce qu'il faut embaucher des actrices
pour jeu des catcheuses ousseynou kâ
catcheuse
moi seigneur saloperies d'actrice
mesdemoiselles
je voudrais vous présenter la nouvelle
star de glace baby gaga est ce que tu te
fous de moi pourquoi est ce que les là
celle-là elle sellal failli tuer l'oméga
soumet toi elle pourrait tuer sebastian
a war notre producteur c'est ma première
fête libyenne il ya de la drogue dans
[ __ ] trop beau
le cactus est basé sur des types était
une fêtarde ultra sexy li té in arabe
qui parle de stéréotypes ou bingo
exactement tu es une grosse homme noir
tu as dit quoi à la ddt efficaces tueuse
j'ai pris chez les femmes peut faire
tout ce que font les hommes la bla bla
ça a donné quoi j'ai des frissons on a
le pouvoir
on sera lire ou tu veux toujours que ce
show soit produit c'est bien le seul
endroit sur terre où je peux faire ce
que j'aime les gens me respectent ici
doit-on et strident jean cinq semaines
ça pourra soit avoir l'air pourri soit à
voir les répliques donc voyons tout ça
en grand et saint denys en temps
histoire bien ficelée d histoire bien
ficelée
là on parle de justice compin de
s'accrocher à ce qui nous appartient
[Musique]
et dames et messieurs je vous présentais
sublime lutteuse de quartier
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
[Musique]
à